sun is a loud dessert and I created it
with vibrant layers representing the
colors of the rainbow to celebrate pride
month throughout this month I am
reaffirming my commitment to living
freely and authentically when I reflect
on our Collective Journey towards love
and acceptance it reminds me of the
importance of embracing who we are and
allowing others to do the same everyone
deserves the opportunity to live a
fulfilling life and pursue happiness so
the next time you come across a rainbow
remember to appreciate it a little bit
more because it represents the colors we
strive to keep shining brightly